that when I graduate I'm going to be a
history teacher history teacher what do
you suggest in the high school what do
you suggest I do in that context to give
them profession well you know that's
really important you know a lot of
people I suspect many of you if you
think of your own experience I know me
you can remember
cases where a teacher really made a
terrific impression on you I mean most
schooling is just train training for
stupidity and conformity but every once
in a while and that's institutional too
there are reasons for that but
occasionally you know you get a spark
somebody will challenge your mind you
know make you think encourage you to
think and so on that is tremendous
effect you know you just reach all sorts
of people of course if you do it you're
going to be you may very well have
problems you have to tread a narrow line
there are plenty of people who don't
want students to think they don't
they're afraid of the crisis of
democracy you know people start thinking
and you get all these problems I was
quoting at the beginning you know they
won't have humility enough to submit to
a civil rule you know all right I'll
start trying to press their demands in
the political arena or they'll you know
have ideas of their own instead of
believing what they're told and
privilege and power typically doesn't
want that so they can react and high
school teacher who tries to get students
to think may find the repression firing
and so on